RITTER JUMPED IN AND SAID HE IS
A BIG BIGGER GUY, SO HE WON'T
CLIP THAT ONE OUT.
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
I DON'T WANT TO DISRUPT THE
FLOW, BUT IT'S TO A 32nd
CONVERSATION HERE.
I TOOK THE SAINTS +2 1/2, I
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE UNDER A
FIELD GOAL WOULD TAKE THE MONEY
LINE.
I LIKE TO HAVE IT IN CASE THEY
MIX EXTRA POINTS, WHAT QUICK 15
SECOND STRATEGY, DO YOU GO FOR
THE BIGGER PAYOUT OR TAKE THE
POINTS?
>> WHEN IT IS +2 2, I TAKE
YOU AND HAVE, WANTED TO HAVE
FOR UNDER, ANYTHING, PICK THEM
BUT ONE OF THE HALF, I WILL
TAKE THE MONEY LINE.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> RYAN, DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE POPPING OFF IN THE CHAT?
>> WE'VE GOT A ROGUE COMMENT.
THEY SAIFORG EVERYTHING HE
SAID, I DON'T CARE.
THE LOCK OF THE DAY IS JUST +6
AND HALF.
>> IS THAT YOUR BURNER ACCOUNT?
>> I'M LOCKED INTO THE CHAT, I
DON'T HAVE TIME TO COMMENT, BUT
I LOVE THAT PLAY TODAY.
AND THE CHAT LOVES THE NINERS.
>> THERE IT IS, THAT IS
TRANSITIONING US TO THE NEXT
PICK.
HE ALREADY GAVE US A LITTLE
PREVIEW OF IT.
SAM, TALK TO ME AND TALK TO THE
PEOPLE.
WHY ARE WE LEANING MINORS -9?
>> A REALLY GOOD JOB
TRANSITIONING FROM LAST COMMENT
BEING ABOUT THE NINERS, THAT IS
A PLUS PRODUCTION.
I LOVE THE NINERS THIS WEEK.
RARELY IN THE NFL I THINK YOU
GETAN EMOTIONAL LETDOWN SPOT,
BUT THE SEAHAWKS LAST WEEK
BASICALLY WON THE SUPER BOWL IN
THEIR MIND.
AND EVERY SINGLE QUOTE, BEATING
ROSS AND EVERY SINGLE QUOTE
FROM EVERY PLAYER AND EVEN PETE
CARROLL WAS LIKE, THIS GAME, I
WANTED TO WIN THIS GAME MORE
THAN ANYTHING.
THEY ABSOLUTELY HATE RUSS OVER
THERE.
YOU SEE THIS ALL THE TIME IN
COLLEGE AFTER A TEAM WINS A
REALLY BEGIN, IT'S HARD TO GET
UP FOR THE NEXT ONE AND LIKE I
SAID, THE SEAHAWKS PRETTY MUCH
HAD THEIR SUPER BOWL.
THIS IS A REALLY GOOD SPOT FOR
THE NINERS ESPECIALLY AFTER A
LOSS AND I LOST THAT AGAIN WILL
GET INTO IN MY OTHER PICK, THAT
BEARS WHEN WAS PRETTY FLUKY IN
A MONSOON, EVERYTHING HAPPENED
FOR THE BEARS.
>> OKAY.
I'M NOT REALLY LISTENING TO
EVERYTHING THAT YOU ARE SAYING,
BUT I STRONGLY BELIEVE IN YOU,
AND I KNOW THAT YOU E SHARP.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE
MINUS -9, LOCKING IT IN.
I DON'T KNOW, BEING A NINERS
FAN, I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO GO
THERE. NO BAD VIBES, I WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PICK.
THE NEXT IS --
>> I'M GLAD YOU ARE COMING OFF
BECAUSE I WAS CONFUSING MYSELF
BUT I WAS RIGHT.
I FIGURED IT OUT.
NEXT PICK, GOING BACK TO THE
BEARS AND WE ARE TAKING PACKS
-10. THAT AGAIN, JUST REPEAT
WHAT I SAID, THAT WHEN AGAINST
THE 49ers WAS JUST, THAT IS
OF E WEATHER AND WEIRD ECAUSE
CONDITIONS.
I'M NOT BUYING THE STEAM THAT
MUCH.
AND AGAIN, ON THE OTHER SIDE,
YOU'RE THE PACKERS COMING OFF A
DIVISIONAL LOSS, THEY ARE GOING
TO WANT TO FOLLOW TO 0-2. IT IS
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME PHILOSOPHY
FROM THE PACKERS AND NINERS.
GETTING OFF THE LOSS GOING
AGAINST TEAMS THAT HAVE FLUKY
WINDS OR EMOTNAL LETDOWN'S.
SO I LOVE THE PACKERS THIS
WEEK.
I THINK THE RIGHT THE SHIP AND
AARON RODGERS OBVIOUSLY OWNS
THE CHICAGO BEARS.
>> WE KNOW WHAT AARON RODGERS
DOES TO THOSE CHICAGO BEARS.
OKAY.
LAST PICK OF THE DAY.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE, TALK TO ME,
WHAT ARE WE WRITING?
>> IT IS ACTUALLY NOT A PIC
TODAY BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
MONDAY SHOW.
SO I'VE GOT TO GIVE THIS UP NOW.
I REALLY LIKE THE EAGLES
TOMORROW. OUR GOOD FRIEND
MICHAEL RIER  PROBABLY
FREAKING OUT IN THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE HE IS THE BIGGEST KIRK
COUSINS FAN, BUT AGAIN, I THINK
THE VIKING SORT OF CONQUERED
DEMONS PROBABLY IS THE RIGHT
WORD, BUT THEY HAD A HUGE WIN
LAST WEEK AGAINST THE PACKERS
NOW GOING MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL
, I REALLY LIKE THE SPOT FOR
THE EAGLES.
I THINK THE EAGLES ARE A VERY
GOOD TEAM AND NOW THAT THE
COWBOYS ABSOLUTELY SUCK, I
THINK THEY WILL UNFORTUNATELY
FOR OUR PRODUCER, RYAN ROLLED
TO THE NFC EAST TITLE, BUT I
LIKE THE EAGLES TEAM, THEY ARE
PRETTY DEEP.
I'M HURT SKYPE.
AND LIKE I SAID ON THE FUTURE
SHOW, I WAS A HERTZ GUY BEFORE
EVERYONE BECAME ONE IN THE
SEASON.
I LIKE THIS, I THINK THEY ARE A
LITTLE BIT BETTER THAN THE
VIKINGS.
>> I WANT TO MAKE A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT POINT TO EVERYBODY
WATCHING THE SHOW ABOUT THAT
GAME IN PARTICULAR.
KIRK COUSINS IS PLAYING IN A
PRIMETIME GAME.
>> I HAD THAT ON MY NOTES.
AND I FORGOT TO MENTION IT.
I'M GLAD THAT YOU DID.
>> I HOPE MICHAEL RITTER IS
PAYING ATTENTION AND HEARTHAT
ONE BECAUSE YOU KNOW HOW HE
LOVES KIRK COUSINS. I
WILL READ THEM OFF FOR YOU.
WE GOT PHILADELPHIA MONEY LINE,
GREEN BAY -10, SAN FRANCISCO
49ers -9, DOING WHAT MONEY
LINE, CAROLINA RYAN UPDATED US
AND SAID SAM MOVED THE LINE.
IT'S -1 NOW. MODESTO PLAYED AT
-1 I'M STILL FINE AT -1
>> AND YOU CARTED AT +2.
SO WINNER CHICKEN DINNER TO
YOU, KUDOS TO YOU.
BUT HOPEFULLY THEY WIN THE -1
AND EVERYONE IS WALKING AWAY
HAPPY.
NEW ORLEANS +2 1/2 BEFORE THE
TRANSITION TO THE NEXT SEGMENT,
I WANT TO TAP IN MY MAN,
PRODUCER RYAN, WHAT IS POPPING
OFF IN THE COMMENTS, BRO?
>> ANOTHER UPDATE ONLINE, 49ers
ARE -8 AND HALF, SO YOU'RE
GETTING IT.
>> NOT AS SHARP ON THAT ONE.
>> YOU HAVE TO BALANCE OUT AND
I'M GETTING BACK THERE FOR THE
MONEY LINE PICK.
WOULDN'T BE A SHOW IF YOU
WEREN'T. ON THE LINE, HE LOVES
THE COLTS MONEY LINE.
>> I LIKE THE COLTS MONEY LINE.
I WAS TALKING TO MY BUDDIES
YESTERDAY ABOUT IT.
THEY HAVE TO BOUNCE BACK FROM
ST WK.
THEY ARE PLAYING THE JAGUARS.
>> KIND OF A REVENGE GAME FOR
THE LAST GAME OF LAST SEASON.
>> PRODUCER RYAN, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU ARE OUR STATS GUY, BUT I
FEEL LIKE THE JAGUARS HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEATEN THE COLTS.
IF YOU PULL UP JAGUARS 10-1 IN
THE LAST 5 YEARS, THAT WOULDN'T
SURPRISE ME.
I'M STAYING AWAY FROM THE GAME.
I HAVEN'T THAT ON THEM TO WIN
THE DIVISION.
I REALLY HOPE THEY WIN IT.
NO MICHAEL PITTMAN TODAY WHICH
I THINK IS TOUGH.
BUT THE JAGUARS ARE FINE.
I THINK IT'S ONE OF THOSE TEAMS
THAT ARE KIND OF ALMOST TOO
TRENDY, THEY WILL BE BETTER
THAN LAST YEAR WITHOUT URBAN
MEYER BUT THEY AREN'T WORLD
BEATERS ANYTHING THE LAST TWO
WEEKS THEY'VE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
TOO POPULAIN TRENDY FOR MY
EYES.
SO STAY AWAY FROM ME, BUT I
DON'T HATE THE PIC.
I LIKE THE COLTS AND I BELIEVE
IN THEM.
>> RUN THROUGH A FEW HERE.
BALLINGER DOESN'T LIKE YOUR
NINERS PICKED.
THERE'S WILL NOT BEAT THE
PACKERS, UNSTED, GIANTS WIN
BY NINE.
CORTEZ G GOYA, PRONUNCIATION.
PACKERS ARE TRASH, HE SAYS
JUSTIN FIELDS WILL GET HIS
FIRST JOB IN GREEN BAY SO CHAD
IS LOW T 50-50.
YOU STARTED OUT HOT A■ND THEN
FADED AS THE PICS CAME IN.
>> THAT SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT.
>> IT IS NOW TIME TO TALK ABOUT
ONE OF MY FAVORITE THAT'S.
LAST YEAR I WAS TEETERING A
LITTLE BIT, BUT THIS YEAR, I'M
ALL IN ON THE ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
SCORE, THAT IS EASY MONEY.
ALL YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IS
ONE PLAYER THAT IS GOING TO
SCORE AND THEN PUT YOUR MONEY
ON THEM AND THEN HOPEFULLY THEY
SCORE.
>> YOU GET RICH.
>> YOU GET RICH, BUT GUYS LIKE
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY OR CAMARO
WHEN HE'S OUT THERE, I CAN NAME
A FEW COMMENTS LIKE THOSE GUYS
THAT USUALLY THAT THE TEAM
OFFENSE DEPENDS ON, IT IS EASY
MONEY.
EASY MONEY.
PRODUCER RYAN, CAN YOU PULL UP
THOSE DRAFT KINGS ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN ODDS SO WE CAN GO
THROUGH THEM, THEY ARE,
AUDIENCE, DROP YOUR PICS.
MAKE SURE YOU FILL UP THE
COMMENTS.
WE WILL PICK THE SQUAD RIGHT
AND GET A BOOST FROM OUR
FRIENDS OVER AT DRAFT KINGS.
PRODUCER RYAN, CAN YOU PLEASE
GO TO THE 49er GAME ? 49ers
VERSUS THEY ARE TAKING ON THE
SEAHAWKS AT HOME.
WE ARE SCROLLING.
SAM, DO YOU THINK YOU KNOW
WHERE I'M GOING HERE?
>> I THINK I DO, AND I
IMMEDIATELY LOVE IT, BUT ARE
YOU GOING DEEBO ?
>> WE ARE.
WHEN THE 49ers GET INSIDE THE
RED ZONE, THE FEED AT M.
THEY LITERALLY FEED HIM THE
BALL IN MULTIPLE WAYS.
THAT'S THE THING.
WE ARE TRYING TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN HERE AND WE WANT IT
IN ANY WAY POSSIBLE.
RUNNING, THROWING, RECEIVING,
JET SWEEP, THEY COULD PUT DEEBO
IN THE WILD.
I LIKE THIS PICK SITTING AT
-130.
I WILL TAKE THAT TO THE BANK.
TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WHO IS YOUR ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
SCORE TODAY?
>> I LOVE THE PIC AND IT'S
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT YOU ARE
THINKING WITH I WANT MULTIPLE
AVENUES TO GET THE TOUCHDOWN.
SO OBVIOUSLY HE'S THE RECEIVER
AND HE RUNS THE BALL.
I'M TAKING KRISTA McCAFFREY
BECAUSE HE'S A RUNNING BACK BUT
HE CATCHES BALL A LOT ALSO.
I THINK THE GIANTS LINEBACKING
FORWARD IS A LITTLE BIWEAK SO
I THINK HE COULD DO SOME DAMAGE
IN THE AIR.
IS OBVIOUSLY AN INCREDIBLE
PLAYER.
AND I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE
I'M BETTING THE PANTHERS, I
THINK THEY WILL BE WINNING AND
I THINK OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU ARE
WINNING AND THE GAME GETS
TIGHT, U RUN THE BALL.
I HIGHLIGHT HIM THIS WEEK.
>> I JUST MENTIONED HIS NAME.
HE IS ALMOST, WHEN HE IS OUT
THERE AND HEALTHY, HE IS ALMOST
ALWAYS IN THE END ZONE FOR THE
PACKERS TEAM.
THEY LEAN ON HIM VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO TO OUR PRODUCER, RYAN.
LET'S GO TO THE CHAT.
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT IN
THE COMMENTS?
>> WE'VE GOT BIG MIKE WHO LOVES
CURTIS SAMUEL TODAY.
HONESTLY, I'M STROLLING
THROUGH, HE LOVES THE
COMMANDERS TODAY.
HE'S GOT CURTIS SAMUEL ANY TIME
IN HIS GOT SCARY TERRY ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN.
JAY HERNANDEZ SAYS BRAXTON
BERRIOS TOUCHDOWN, THOSE ARE
JUST ODDS IF YOU LIKE THE JETS
TODAY WHICH I ARTIE SAID I DO.
AND THENACKS, BERKELEY, WE
TALK ABOUT THIS GIANTS GAME AND
SAM, I KNOW YOU ON THE OTHER
SIDE WITH McCAFFREY, BUT WE
LIKE THAT?
>> I DO LIKE SEQUIN.
DID YOU SEE HIM IN WEEK ONE?
HE LOOKED LIKE A MAN ON A
MISSION.
>> HE IS BACK.
HE CAN KIND OF BE IN THAT
CATEGORY OF McCAFFREY WHEN HE
IS HEALTHY, THE TEAM LEANS ON
HIM.
HE MENTIONED DANIEL JONES IS
THE QUARTERBACK.
SO I DON'T DISAGREE ABOUT HIM,
BUT, SAM, I'M STRUGGLING ON MY
DEEBO PICK . -- STRONG ON MY
DEEBO PICK.
DANIEL JONES, NOT VERY GOOD.
I THINK THEY RELIED ON HIM A
TON LAST WEEK AND I INK THEY
LEFT THE DO IT PRETTY MUCH
EVERY GAME THIS YEAR TO HAVE A
CHANCE.
I LIKE McCAFFREY TO SCORE, BUT
I THINK HE WILL GET A TON OF
LOOKS TODAY.
>> SAM LIKES IT.
RYAN, WHERE ARE WE GOING WITH
IT?
WHAT ARE PEOPLE SAYING?
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING?
ARE WE GOING SAKE ONE -- WHERE
IS THE SQUAD AT?
>> THE PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF
TICS.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE
GALVANIZING THE GIANTS AND
BERKELEY TODAY.
THAT'S WHERE THE CHAT IS
LEANING.
>> I KNOW YOU ARE A NEW YORK
FAN AND PROBABLY 30 MINUTES OR
SO AWAY FROM THE STADIUM, NO
BIAS, YOU ARE SURE THAT'S WHAT
THE PEOP ARE ROCKING WITH?
>> I AM A COWBOYS FAN, MY RULE
OF THUMB IS THAT AGAINST THE
GIANTS, I WISH I DIDN'T HAVE TO
SAY THIS, BUT WE ARE GOING WITH
SAQUON BARKLEY .
>> YOU KNOW HOW WE DO IT HERE,
WE GOT THAT THING OSTED.
YOU ALREADY KNOW.
WE BOOSTED IT UP FROM -145 TO
+120 AND THEY ARE ONLY DOING
THAT FOR US.
WE ARE BIDDING IN THE DRAFTING
SQUAD.
SHOUT OUT TO THEM.
SAM, IT IS NOW TIME.
IT IS NOW TIME FOR THE PARLAY
OF THE WEEK.
I'M SO EXCITED.
EARLIER IN THE WEEK, WE POSTED
A CLIP AMG POSTED A STORY,
NOT A STORY, I'M SORRY, POSTED
A CLIP OF A THAT.
AND IT WAS A 15 LEG, I BELIEVE.
AND IT RESULTED IN I BELIEVE IT
WAS -106 WITH THE ODDS OR WAS
IT +106?
>> SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> YES.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
+106 AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS
CRAZY, BUT IT WAS VERY
INTERESTING.
AND ACTUALLY ENGAGE PRETTY WELL
ON THE PAGE AND HAVE A LOT OF
COMMENTS.
I EVEN COMMENTED IN THEIR AND A
LOT OF THE FANS COMMENTED.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU KNOW, LET
ME PUT MY CAPON, MY WINNERS ONLY
CAPE AND MY WINNERS ONLY AND
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
HIT ONE OF THESE PARLAYS.
SO YOU WANT TO GET RIGHT TO IT?
>> LET'S DO IT.
I ALSO JUST LOVED WHAT THEY
CALLED IT BELOW, THERE'S NO WAY
THIS LOSES UNLESS A METEOR
CRASHES INTO THE EARTH PARLAYS
MAYBE MY FAVORITE THING EVER.
I LOVE THAT.
>> THERE IS NO WAY THIS LOSES.
I'VE BEEN IN THE LAB.
I DON'T THINK YOU UNDERSTAND.
PRODUCER MATT HAS HAD ME
SITTING IN THE PARLAY 15 TIMES
SO I HAD TO THINK ABOUT IT, 15
TIMES.
SO I'VE BEEN IN THE LAB ABOUT
THIS AND WE WILL GERIGHT TO
IT.
FIRST OFF, ACTUALLY, CAN WE,
PRODUCER RYAN, ARE YOU --
VARIOUS.
PRODUCER RYAN IS THERE, LET'S
START OFF THE MIAMI DOLPHINS.
ALTERNATE SPREAD.
LET'S GO TO THE ALTERNATE
SPREAD IF WE CAN.
AND THEN GO ALL THE WAY DOWN,
BROTHER.
ALL THE WAY DOWN UNTIL WE CAN'T
ANYMORE.
+17, LOCKE THAT ONE.
THAT IS ONE NOW YOU TALK ABOUT
THBEARS COME HE TALKED ABOUT
THE BEARS, LET'S GO TO THE BEARS
. LET'S GO TO THE BEARS,
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THIS GAME.
WILL THIS GAME BE CLOSE?
MAYBE AND MAYBE NOT.
BUT WILL IT BE A BLOWOUT?
I DON'T THINK SO.
GO TO THE BEARS AND GO ALL THE
WAY DOWN, PRODUCER RYAN, UNTIL
YOU CAN'T GO ANYMORE AND CLICK
THAT.
THAT IS LEG NUMBER TWO.
LET'S MOVE ON.
THE NEXT LEG OF THE PARLAY, THE
NEXT LEG OF THE PARL IS THE
VIKINGS.
MONDAY NIGHT GAME.
VIKINGS, EAGLES. THERE IT IS.
GO TO THE VIKING SIDE AND THEN
GO ALL THE WAY DOWN. ALL THE
WAY DOWN.
>> THIS ENTIRE PARLAY IS ST
RYAN, SCROLL ALL THE WAY DOWN.
ALL THE WAY DOWN. WE ARE TRYING
TO GET AS MANY POINTS AS WE CAN
WITH THIS PARLAY.
WE LOCKED IN THE VIKINGS.
IS THAT TREE?
>> THAT IS THREE. HOW ARE YOU
FEELING ABOUT IT?
>> I'M FEELING LIKE
>> WE WILL GO TO HOUSTON.
HOUSTON, WE MIGHT HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THIS PARLAY. RYAN,
YOU ALREADY KNOW WHAT TO DO,
SCROLLALTHE WAY DOWN.
>> GO ALL THE WAY DOWN, +24,
LOCKE THAT IN.
LET'S MOVE ON.
WE GOT THE TEXANS, RHINE,
FALCONS.
THEY ARE PLAYING THE RAMS IN LA
, CLICK IT AND THEN WE WILL
SCROLL ALL THE WAY DOWN AND IT
SHOULD BE AROUND 20 SOMETHING
POINTS WE GET WITH THAT.
AND I ABSOLUTELY LOVE THAT
NUMBER.
>> WE JUST HAVE TO PRAY THAT
THERE ARE NO BLOWOUTS ALL WEEK.
BECAUSE THAT IS OUR STRATEGY
THIS WEEK.
>> THAT IS LITERALLY HOW YOU
PLAY THESE.
THE NFL IS A COMPETITIVE LEAGUE.
WE ARE JUST CONNECTING THE DOTS
OF THE SHOW.
THE NFL IS A COMPETITIVE
LEAGUE.
DIDN'T WANT BLOWOUTS.
THEY GET BLOWN OUT 77 TO 0,
WILL BE ON RADIO TALK AND ESPN,
JERRY JONES WILL BE GOING
CRAZY.
THEY DON'T WANT THAT IN THE
NFL.
SO GUESS WHAT, WE WILL BET LIKE
THAT.
PRODUCER RYAN, BILLS, I NEED
THE BILLS, AND THEN FOR THIS ONE
, YOU AREN'T EVEN GOING TO HAVE
TO SCROLL ALL THE WAY DOWN.
GO TO THE TOP.
THERE IT IS.
YES, SIR.
PRODUCER, RHINE, BUFF
+2 AND HALF, NO WAY THEY ARE
LOSING THAT GAME.
>> YOU KNOW IT'S A GREAT PARLAY
, WHEN YOU ARE SHOCKED THAT A
LEG IS AS LOW AS -630.
THAT WAS THE LOWEST ODDS WE
GOT, -630.
I LOVE THIS.
THIS IS HEADING.
>> I'M TELLING YOU, SAM,
PRODUCER RYAN, CINCINNATI
BENGALS.
>> COWBOYS MONEYLINE.
>> WE ARE TALKING A LOT.
>> ALL THE WAY DOWN, PRODUCER
RYAN.
ALL THE WAY DOWN, PLEASE.
THERE IT IS.
>> THIS IS A LOCK.
AFTER THE BANGLES, LET'S GO TO
THE COMMANDERS.
THERE THEY ARE FACING THE
DETROIT LIONS.
YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO.
GO AHEAD AND TAKE AND CLICK THA
>> I NEED A T-SHIRT THAT SAYS
PRODUCER RYAN, SCROLL ALL THE
WAY DOWN.
WE HAVE TO TAKE SOME CUSTOM
MERCHANDISE BECAUSE THIS IS MY
FAVORITE THING.
>> SAM LIKES IT, I LOVE IT.
LET'S MOVE ON BECAUSE I'VE GOT
TWO MORE LEGS FOR YOU GUYS.
TAMPA BAY.
>> LET ME GUESS.
>> WAIT, SAM, SAM, I NEED YOUR
HELP HERE.
VE GOT BUCCANEERS +11.
YOU ARE ROCKING WITH THE
SAINTS, SHOULD WE RIDE WITH THE
SAINTS ON THIS ONE?
>> BECAUSE THIS IS YOUR NO WAY
THIS LOSES UNLESS A METEOR
CRASHES INTO THE EARTH, TRUST
YOUR GUT.
GREAT VALUE AT -740.
I LOVE IT.
>> HE SAID TRUST THE GOT SO
THAT'S WHAT WE WILL DO.
PRODUCER RYAN, YOU KNOW WHAT TO
DO, CLICK THE BOX +11 BECAUSE
WE ARE LOCKING THAT IN AND FOR
THE FINAL AND LAST LEG, THE
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS,
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS.
>> I'M SO EXCITED TO SEE WHAT
THE FINAL PAYOUT OF THIS IS.
THIS IS THE LAST LEG.
I WANT TO SEE, ARE WE STILL IN
PLUS TERRITORY OR DID WE GET
ALL THE WAY TO -120?
>> WE MIGHT END UP IN PLUS
TERRITORY IS GOOD.
IF YOU WANT MONEY AND YOU WANT
TO WINCLICK THAT, BROTHER.
AND THEN LET US KNOW.
LET US KNOW WHAT THOSE ODDS ARE.
>> +231
>> +231 GREG, LOOK AT THAT.
>> CAN WE SHOW THE ENTIRE PARLAY
? I'VE AN INSIDE SOURCE ON THE
APP TO YOU THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THE COMMENT SECTION ARE
ASKING TO SEE THE ENTIRE TICKET
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WANT TO ROLL
WITH GREG.
>> THE CHAT IS TRYING TO
PRODUCE PRODUCER RYAN RIGHT NOW
AND THEY WANT THE WHOLE TICKET.
>> INSTEAD OF A FAST SCROLL,
GIVE THEM A's SLOW SCROLL.
>> GET THE SCREEN GRABS READY,
HERE WE GO.
>> GO ALL THE WAY DOWN, HAVE TO
GO FAST, BUT NOW WE WANTTO
SLOW DOWN.
>> I'M SO SORRY, GO TO THE TOP
AND LET ME READ IT TO THE
PEOPLE.
WHILE YOU SCROLL.
HERE WE GO, FROM THE TOP, MIAMI
DOLPHINS +17 ABSOLUTELY LOVE
THAT ONE CHICAGO BEARS, +24,
MINNESOTA VIKINGS +15.
HOUSTON TEXANS +24. THE ATLANTA
FALCONS WAS 24.
BUFFALO BILLS +2 1/2.
CINCINNATI BENGALS +5,
WASHINGTON COMMANDERS +13 AND
HALF, TAMPA BAY BUCS, +11 AND
WRAPPING IT UP FOR US ARE THE
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS PLUS 10 GET
ON DRAFT KINGS AND LOCK IT IN
YOURSELF. IT IS RIGHT THERE IN
FRONT OF YOU, IT'S +231, THOSE
ARE GOOD ODDS.
TALK TO ME, RYAN, TALK TO ME,
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ABOUT THE
PARLAY?
>> I LOVE THE NAME, I LOVE THE
VIBES.
I SOLULY LOVE IT.
AND LET'S JUST HOPE A METEOR
DOESN'T CRASH INTO THE EARTH
AND THIS BET CASHES, THIS IS
ONE OF MY FAVORITE THINGS EVER.
>> LET'S HOPE A METEOR DOES NOT
CRASH INTO THE EARTH.
RYAN, DO YOU HAVE ANY WORDS?
>> FOR VIBES, I LOVE THIS.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
BANGLES LEG IS IN THEIR.
THAT'S KIND OF THE ONLY ONE
THAT'S THE CLOSEST THING WE
HAVE TO A MONEYLINE.
I LOVE IT.
>> RYAN LIKES IT, SAM LIKES IT,
GET ON DRAFT KINGS AND GO THAT
IT.
LET'S GET TO MY NEXT FAVORITE
THAT, THIS IS A NEW ONE, AN
EARLY WHEN. THE GIST OF THIS
ONE IS YOU CAN PLACE SOME
MONEYLINE BETS ON ANY TEAM AND
AT ANY POINT YOUR TEAM GOES UP
10 POINTS, YOU WIN.
EVEN IFUR TEAM LOSES.
THEY JUST HAVE TO GO UP 10
POINTS AND YOU WILL WIN, IT IS
EASY AS THAT.
SAM, I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN IN THE
LAB THINKING OF A TEAM THAT YOU
THINK IS GOING TO GO UP 10,
ICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING HERE?
>> I ALSO SHOULD SAY, THIS
PROMO CASH FOR BOTH TEAMS IN
THE THURSDAY NIGHT GAME BECAUSE
CHARGERS AND CHIEFS BOTH WENT
UP SEVEN.
SO LIKE THAT, THAT'S INCREDIBLE
IF YOU CAN GET BOTH MONEY LINES
CASHED OUT, BUT YES.
I USE THIS PROMO WITH MY PATS
THAT.
SO I TOOK PATS MONEYLINE IN THE
GOLD 10, AND CACHING EARLY AND
I LOVE THAT.
I'M STICKING WITH MY PATS, WHO
ARE YOU ROLLING WITH?
>> SAM, I THINK I'M GOING TO
RIDE WITH THE TEAM FROM
BUFFALO.
I'M GOING TO RIDE WITH THE
BUFFALO BILLS HERE.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GO UP
EARLY AND OFTEN AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THE TITANS ARE GOING TO
KEEP UP WITH SCORING WITH THEM.
SO 10 POINTS.
YOU CAN SEE THEM GOING TO GET
THAT.
AND THEY ARE COASTING TO
VICTORY.
GET ON DK AND GET YOUR BET IN.
OVER OR UNDER, WE WILL PLAY A
LITTLE GAME.
EACH ACTOR, I'M JUST GOING TO
GET RIGHT TO IT.
I'M GOING TO NAME SOME PLAYERS,
AND WE ARE GOING TO GO OVER OR
UNDER THEIR PROP THAT I'M
CONFUSING MYSELF ALREADY.
OVER OR UNDER,  SAQUON BARKLEY,
75 RUSHING YARDS . I'M GOING
OVER.
THE IT IS.
I THINK NEW YORK WILL LEAN ON
TRANSLATE -- SAQUON BARKLEY .
>> I THINK WE SHOULD RAPIDFIRE
THESE.
I'M TRYING TO DO WHAT THE APP
COMMENTS ARE DOING, THAT'S
PRODUCER RYAN THIS JOB. LET'S
RAPIDFIRE THESE, I THINK THEY
WILL GIVE SAQUON BARKLEY  THE
BALL A LOT.
TOM BRADY COME OVER UNDER
PASSING TOUCHDOWNS, HE'S PLAYING
THE SAINTS, SO I'M GOING UNDER.
I'M GOING UNDER.
>> SAINTS OWN BRADY.
YOU GET NICE VALUE AND I THINK
IT'S +150.
>> THEY DEFINITELY OWN BRADY.
PRODNOW?
E THEY FILLING OVER AND UNDER
PICS?
>> QUICK BREAKING NEWS, SAM, NOT
GREAT FOR THE SAINTS PICK,
ALVIN IS OUT TODAY.
IT IS OFFICIAL.
BUT THE COMMENTS, GREG, THEY
ARE LOVING YOU.
WE'VE GOT JACKSON SAYING HE'S
RIDING WITH YOU.
ANOTHER SAYS BRADY QUITS TODAY,
SEEMS COULD WIN.
BAMA VOICES SAINTS VERSUS BUCS
OVER.
THE CHAT WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
WHATHEY NT TO TALK ABOUT,
THEY HAVE NO TAKES.
WE'VE GOT, LET'S SEE.
>> CAN I SAY SOMETHING?
IF PEOPLE ARE RIDING WITH
GREG'S PARLAY, WHEN THE TICKET
CASHES, WE WILL POST THE
WINNING TICKET.
DM THAT TO GREG, DON'T DM IT TO
ME OR PRODUCER RYAN.
>> I SAY WE HIT, LET'S GO TO
VEGAS NEXT MONTH.
WHY NOT?
LET'S MOVE ON.
PRODUCER RYAN, YOU COULD BE
HERE FOR THIS ONE, RAPID FIRE,
MITCHELL TRUBISKY, OVER OR
UNDER HALF INTERCEPTIONS.
>> WAY OVER.
>> I'M GOING OVER.
>> YOU'VE GOT A LINE ONERY
PICKED.
I LOVE THIS.
>> YOU KNOW HOW WE DO.
LET'S MOVE ON.
JOE MIXON, OVER UNDER, LONGEST
RUSH, 15 1/2 YARDS, THAT'S A
TOUGH ONE.
>> I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO
DO WITH THIS ONE.
JUST OVER UNDER LONGEST RUSH, A
CRAZY BET.
I SAID OVER AND I THINK HE HIT
60% OF THE GAMES LAST YEAR.
THAT WAS MY THINKING.
>> 15 1/2, HE WILL HAVE TO
BREAK ONE HE DOES BREAK QUITE A
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M PUTTING MY
MONEY ON THAT.
LET'S MOVE ON.
DAVANTE ADAMS, OVER OR UNDER,
THAT IS EASY, THAT'S NOT EVEN A
QUESTION.
RYAN IS GOING UNDER, YET THE
TALKED WAS, WHY ARE YOU GOING
UNDER?
>> HUNTER RERO LEGACY GAME.
>> HE GETS BACK INTO THE CHAT.
>> LOVE THAT.
I GOT HUNTER RENFRO ON MY
FANTASY TEAM, AND HE DIDN'T
REALLY DO ANYTHING IN WEEK ONE
SO I NEED HIM TO STEP IT UP.
TALK TO US ABOUT THOSE COMMENTS.
ARE THEY ON-TOPIC ORARTHEY
ALL OVER THE PLACE?
>> THEY ARE GETTING ON-TOPIC.
AND WHEN SAYS OVER FOR THE
LOWEST RUSH FOR MIXON.
HE ALSO LIKES THE OVER FOR THE
INTERCEPTIONS.
WAVY BABY IS REALLY TRYING TO
GET MY ATTENTION.
HE LIKES THE JETS MONEYLINE
LIKE I SAID, JU THE POINTS,.
WE GOT OVER RECEPTIONS FOR
DIAMANTC
MIKE SAYS 20+ YARD RUN FOR
MIXON TODAY.
UNLOCKING IT IN.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> I GUARANTEE YOU GUYS THERE
WAS LOTS GIVEN IN THIS SHOW.
IT IS UP TO YOU GUYS TO FADE OR
FOLLOW SAM RYAN, I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR US TO GET UP OUT OF
YOUR AND PUT SOME BETS IN AND
GET READY FOR THIS NFL SUNDAY.
SO MY NAME IS GREG IVEY, FOR
SAM RICHMAN AND MY MAN,
PRODUCER RYAN, WE ARE OUT,
PEACE.
[ MUSIC ]